ladies and gentlemen please join me in
welcoming Walter Isaacson how great it
is to be here at the computer thanks for
being is iam well we're one wonderful
place can I give a shout out to Steve
Wozniak well I just saw and his wife
Joyce wash it up Andy Hertzfeld that
stole my thinkin so all the history is
here totally intimidating me cuz I'll
keep looking over and they'll be going
nodding or shaking their head no no no
it wasn't that way exactly but Jeff I'll
look over there that's what Mike use
this is a Silicon Valley crowd Walter
they won't be that polite oh dear well
we're so happy to have you here thank
you having me appreciate it
let me ask you about your very very
first meeting with Steve Jobs 1984 you
describe yourself as junior editor time
he comes to New York to demonstrate the
Macintosh and you set go you see both
sides of Steve you know that absolutely
passionate side cuz there he is with the
original Mac that thing sitting there
that almost looks like it's smiling at
you he make sure that the strip up there
he shows us how thin it is so it looks
like a friendly face not in the under
Thal face and he shows us all the
graphical icons and you can tell he's
passionate about every pixel he's also
furious at Time magazine tells us that
you know we're not nearly as good as
Newsweek that somebody I won't name his
name because their lives he had written
a horrible story about him and so I saw
the petulant side and if that's when I
first started to realize that the the
sort of impatience and petro ism that
you sometimes saw in Steve Jobs was
connected to the passion in the
perfectionism you were meeting
incredible people you have met
incredible people during your career was
there something special about that
encounter did he make a particular
impression on you at
I must admit I was mesmerized by him
he's a very compelling because I mean
you saw it there that's what he was then
and he's telling you these stories he
was up for mana he was mad because he
had not been made man of the year for
the end of 1982 I of course have been an
idiot on the wrong side of that and I'd
voted for Paul Volcker and none of you
remember who Paul Volcker was but we had
done the machine moves in it was sort of
machine of the year and so but you could
tell the first time you met Steve Jobs
that there was something compelling
about him so flash forward 20 years it's
2004 and he gets in touch with you yeah
it gives me a call and I just joined the
astronaut a little while I said do you
want to come speak in ask me said no but
I want to come take a walk with you and
after a while he says why don't you do a
biography of me he sort of suggests sit
I had done Ben Franklin was just
finishing Albert Einstein so I thought
okay you know Franklin Einstein Steve
I'm thrashing I'm sure that was on his
mind but I admit I said you know you're
a really really great subject but let's
wait 30 years until you retire then it
wasn't until 2009 when he had his liver
transplant went on that medical leave
that it sort of sunk in that he was
fighting cancer that he had transformed
with his team a wide variety of
industries you know first home computing
and personal computing but by that point
by 2009 had transformed the music
industry with iTunes and the iPod the
way we listen to music the phone
industry the publishing industry tablet
computing so that's when I said all
right you know this is this is too good
to pass up did you have a theory about
him going into this I had a theory
because his very first phone call when
we started talking about it he told me
something that Edwin land had said to
him which is that you always want to
stand at the intersection of liberal
arts and the sciences you know right
there between the humanities
and the humanities and technology or
engineering and that's something we kind
of lost in the CP snow era where you
know you either were in the humanities
are you in the sciences and my theory
among others was that connecting
creativity to wonderful feats of
engineering was what made him so magical
you wrote something in the book hmm a
quote his passion for perfection led him
to indulge his instinct to control so I
want to talk to you about the editorial
control question because you must have
had to graze that and settle it fairly
early on how did you manage to do that I
was stunned because it never really came
up and then after a while he kept saying
was your book it's your book I'm not
even gonna read it he did say by the way
people don't read books you know yeah so
I don't yeah but it's yours and by the
way I wanted to be honest I want you to
interview you know people who didn't
like me as well as people did and he
said you know that he was brutally
honest his whole life he said he did not
want it to feel like an in-house book he
wanted to feel like an independent book
and therefore he was going to exercise
no editorial control did that ever
change did he ever call you up and well
the one time he did which fits into a
serie of people don't read books but
they look at him as simon and schuster
about a year ago put into the catalogue
sort of a cover design just there was a
placeholder and it was a cover of
Stephen an apple you know with ice Steve
as a title I landed in San Francisco
Airport coming to a product launch that
he was going to do I came up which one
but maybe the iPad and I saw the thing
you least like to see on your iPhone
which is six or seven missed calls from
Steve Jobs
so y'all know the San Francisco Airport
I'm standing there right in the
concourse I had returned and he just
starts yelling at me he said you have no
taste
you know it's hoes and you know the
title is gimmicky and it's just ugly and
I don't even want you to come to the
demonstration I'm holding the phone you
know and finally he says I'm not gonna
continue to cooperate unless you allow
me to have input into the cover art now
it took me somewhere between a second
and a second and a half to say sure you
know here's the greatest design I you
know for something like that and he
spent a lot of time you know just trying
to make it a very simple clean cover and
so that was the one time I felt his
wrath and also the one time when he had
editorial input you know you talk a lot
about and you quote his friends who who
coined the term reality distortion field
yeah did you find yourself getting
sucked into that from time to time as
you started working with him well I
think you'd be the last to know reality
Distortion feel that it's about it and
talk to me about it
and revolution the valley but it was you
know the engineers there comes from a
Star Trek series which is simply by
thinking something and being convinced
of something even if it's impossible you
know you can convince other people and
then the secret of the reality
distortion field is that it sometimes
works that you convince people they can
do the impossible was talked about that
to me and in his own book about you know
Steve saying you'll have to do this in
four days I think it was you know one of
the Atari games they were doing and one
said it can't be done and Steve said you
can do it and that was a reality
distortion field and four days had been
done so the question of whether I got
sucked into it I found myself deeply
emotionally vested with him I tried very
hard to be honest in the book to put all
things and all sides in the book but
there will probably this will be people
in this audience they would know more
than you know most if you read the book
and say boy this guy got caught in a
reality distortion field I guess the
answer would be yes so one want a final
question about the process of writing
the book and then we'll the one we want
is sort of it the sense of Steve you had
the luxury of a kind of long historical
detachment from Einstein from Benjamin
Franklin not so much with Kissinger but
here you are suddenly writing a
biography of a very compelling living
person up close and personal with him in
40 interviews
how does embargo for maintaining that
kind of necessary detachment that you
could enjoy just by not being able to
spend time with Einstein or Franklin
well a couple of things you know when
Steve did his stanford speech he said
let me you know let me tell you three
stories that just three stories you
become a storyteller you don't try to
preach and I just tried to let the
stories tell themselves one of the
things I discovered by having so much
time with them and so much time with 150
other people who work with him was how
much more we know or I could know about
him than I did about Benjamin Franklin
or Einstein and we thank you know
Benjamin Franklin wrote a lot of letters
40 volumes of papers Einstein they're
still compiling his papers so we should
know more but like the flying the kite
in the rain yeah we got one little
journal entry where there's maybe a
newspaper clip but with Steve everything
that happened I'd hear about it at great
length and then hear other people's
versions of it and I probably ended up
knowing a hundred maybe a thousand times
more about him and each story in the
book than you would doing somebody who
you're doing it through letters or
journals ok let's talk about the the
storytelling now and the place I'd like
to begin
is his partnership with Wozniacki it
starts with that very early dance the
blue box right well that starts at Atari
actually by doing games where Steve is
on the night shift because it's they
find it easier to work with him if he's
on the night shift and he learns a lot
at Atari including the notion of how to
juice up chips and make them do amazing
things and also simplicity I mean you
have to remember that games like pong
and breakout and Star Trek they had to
be so simple that a stone freshman could
figure them out you know so there's like
the instructions were insert quarter
avoid Klingons or something and so that
simplicity got embedded in him then at
one point you have one of the few copies
at the Computer History Museum of the
blue box which was started I think when
Esquire magazine wrote about Captain
Crunch and the phone freaker's who could
replicate the bell systems tones and
let's make free phone calls and so woz
and Steve Jobs said we got to do this
went to slack the Stanford Linear
Accelerator you know library there found
the Bell System manuals and made an
analog version of that that didn't quite
work woz goes off to Berkeley but in his
first semester there is able to make the
first digital version of it and it there
you see the partnership and I
unfortunately I can't say he was whether
he shake his head but was it comes up
with this amazing circuit board but of
course you know loves to show it off
Steve says we can package it and we can
sell it and make money so they start
going door-to-door and rooms and
Berkeley selling this thing at one point
testing it out by I think calling the
Vatican and woz pretended to be Henry
Kissinger saying that he was at a summit
meeting and needed to speak to the Pope
I can see was is nodding at this one as
far as I can tell they never really got
the Pope on the phone that the entire
College of Cardinals was smart
enough eventually to figure out it was
not Henry Kissinger calling but you know
they showed the thing off and Steve Toby
when he described that story and the
whole blue box story that if it hadn't
been for the blue box it wouldn't have
been Apple that's pretty profound and
why did he feel that way what was the
thing that they could do together that a
very complimentary meaning that
complemented each other well I mean he
would say of laws that he could 50 times
better than any engineer could have
meetings in his head and designed great
circuit boards was I had been taught by
you know his father being an engineer is
the highest calling so he never thought
about maybe we should put it in a
package maybe we should get you know
great cases maybe we should get a good
power supply and integrated maybe we can
sell it at twice or three times the cost
of our materials and so what Steve did
was as he did his whole life take really
great ideas and come up with a great
vision and pull it all together to do
something amazing and I think that was a
perfect partnership for somebody who was
you know could design a circuit board
with one quarter of the number of chips
that any other engineer would take to
make it work we were talking earlier too
about the process of invention is not a
singular endeavor it's not the one
person sitting in a room finding out
that yeah yeah it really is about it's
about that collaboration have you when
you think of Einstein for example was
there a relationship have you and you
found through history and as a
journalist that these kinds of
relationships recur over and over you
find Wozniak in jobs you find other
people you know not always with Einstein
it was a true solo act especially the
greatest of most elegant of theories of
the 20th century general relativity he's
pacing alone in his apartment in Berlin
for months on end and unlike most other
physicists at a time Max Planck Niels
Bohr
he didn't former school and wasn't
collaborative Steve even though he was
sometimes tough on people truly created
team
like the original Macintosh team of
which Andy was a part that were bonded
together as if they were pirates in a
pirate band and Steve was able with his
both inspiring way and demanding way to
create collaborative teams and he's done
that is how he did that his whole life I
mean even now for the past eight or nine
years at Apple you've had an intensely
loyal great collaborative team so Apple
gets up and running and they share art
with just so I can give a shout out to
everyone and anyone we have brought us
all our friends here yeah the Apple one
showing that that was what you've heard
on the tape where they go purvey it to
Paul Terrell at the byte shop it gets up
and running when they create that
circuit when blahs creates a circuit
board and then they put it all together
Steve decides they have to incorporate
in fact they sold today at Sotheby's for
one point some odd million yeah 1.6
million yeah the wood Ron Wayne Steve
Jobs and Wozniak signed when they put
together Apple the way Steve tells me
the story he had worked on the all one
farm a commune one buy people would
greed college work they had all dropped
out of Reed gone to this apple farm he
was there tending to the Gravenstein
apples and had come back from the apple
farm and says okay we're gonna create a
company and they you know it gets all
excited that you know not only we're
gonna make a product we'll have our own
company and they couldn't figure out
what today meant they'd have all sorts
of executrix and matrix and personal
computers Inc but Steve says what about
just Apple Apple Computer
counter-intuitive makes your head snap a
bit the kind of friendly has a width of
the counterculture but it's also it's as
American as pie and I think says if we
can't think of a better name within a
day we'll register at its Apple Computer
and they said and by the way our guest
in front of Atari in the phone book
important marketing angle so they begin
to work on the Apple one Apple is
growing they're putting together this
team early in the the early history of
the post incorporation period but
there's another ingredient that has to
come along to make it work right Mike
Markkula
comes out to the scene well first of all
you need money right because what
they're doing is going from the Apple
one to the Apple two if you notice among
the differences you know Jerry Manik and
others create I mean what's a manic but
you know create a beautiful case they
need the plastic molding it's gonna cost
a lot of money to do it you can't just
sell your VW bus and your HP calculator
the way they did to get the Apple one so
they need investment capital and Mike
Markkula comes along signs a line of
credit but also gives them a great piece
so give Steve a great piece of advice
which is a marketing document with three
concepts on it one is to focus really
you know keep your focus the other is
empathy not the perfect word for it but
it's basically make an emotional
connection with the people gonna buy
your products and then the third is also
not a great word the words impute but it
means casts an aura around whatever you
do so that the minute you you know Steve
even throughout this career had his own
personal name on the patents for the
boxes the packaging of the Apple product
so when you opened up and there was that
I pod cradled you it imputed that it was
something really cool just the way the
Apple 2 does it impute said it's a
really cool machine
well then even as primitive as it looks
to us today he obsessed with the curve
of the corners on the edges chamfers and
all the design
you know he had been fascinated by the
Sony style in the very right when they
move out of the garage they're in sort
of a little office and next door is a
Sony showroom and he would fondle the
brochures then he went to Aspen Design
Conference he got invited and really
having grown up in a Joseph eichler
house and I know Joseph Eichler his
grandson is here selling the books with
Keppler but those eichler homes were
sort of mass-marketed simple Frank Lloyd
Wright's style homes for the everyman
but it was simplicity and it was that
Bauhaus style of make it simple but the
simplicity is the ultimate
sophistication and so clean white simple
that becomes a style for Apple it's
about this time as the as Apple grows as
a company the Apple 2 takes off they're
selling hundreds of thousands of units
the phrase in the book surfaces
temperamental and bratty yeah and it
seems at this point there's an almost
there's a there's a kind of break out a
very particular kind of break out at
this point where that side of jobs that
sort of very petulant I think is the
word you use a lot temperamental and
bratty us out other people described it
and it starts to grate on people right I
think you're right he was temperamental
I mean that's why he was on the night
shift at Atari this wasn't something new
but you know temperamental people also
have the temperament of an artist which
is why you have a passion to have
end-to-end control of a product and make
it perfect that temperamental miss you
know there was you know there was an
original president Mike Scott Scotty
sort of tried to temper jobs and didn't
work too well eventually they bring in
John Sculley here's a very polite
gentleman to try to you know handle
Steve but but what Steve you got the
whole package the temperamental miss was
a part of it and it showed just in how
he cared even you know I tell the story
in the book was Steve walking me by his
house that he grew up in
the house when he was very young and his
dad he built a fence with his dad and he
showed me the fence and we touched it he
said my dad taught me to make the back
of the fence as beautiful as the front
and I asked my dad why nobody will ever
see it nobody ever know and my dad said
but you will know and that's why even on
the Apple - he wants a circuit board to
be beautiful and when they get to the
Macintosh the next one over even though
you cannot open it he holds it up for a
while because the chips on the circuit
board are not neatly aligned and when
they say but nobody can open it nobody
will know he says - the Mac designers
but you will know and the other thing
that's interesting in talking about yes
Steve Wozniak Steve Jobs and those two
things is Steve Jobs had the passion of
an artist to have end-to-end control
Hardware integrated with software don't
open it up woz his view was much more
open that we could license out the
software but on the Apple - I think it
had eight slots you know you could jack
into it you could put stuff in - you
could open it up you could get to the
circuit board and Steve was against
Steve Jobs was against having slots he
wanted as an artist would you know he
wouldn't want Bob Dylan saying let's
have an open source on my lyrics you
know everybody can put the words they
want he didn't like people jacking and
opening up woz kind of insists that he
wants the Apple to to have these jacks
the slots but the Macintosh doesn't and
the Macintosh didn't even have screws
that you can use to open it up and that
was very Steve Jobs like all the way
through his career really believing in
tightly controlling like the gardens of
Kyoto that he loved to visit carefully
curated carefully walled carefully
tended by one artist Sensibility so
let's move now to the Macintosh era so
much is going on at Apple at that point
there's so much growth and his personal
courtship of John Sculley begins he
talked a little bit about that that
honor was relation it was a bad
I mean it was almost like he saw John
Sculley a bit as a father figure or a
mentor
Scully really wanted to be cool and hip
and wanted Steve's approval and it was
for a while you know the famous line I
think it's at the San Remo apartment
that Steve is thinking of buying and he
brings John Sculley up and New York
they're looking over Central Park and
Scully's demure ring and Steve says do
you want to spend the rest of your life
because if Scully was at Pepsi you know
selling sugar water or do you want to
change the world and so Scully comes and
Scully
is a man of prep-school sensibilities
great manners very kind but he's hard
it's hard for him to deal with conflict
Steve felt the price I mean I'd say why
were you so tough he said it was the
price of admission to being with me is
that I got to be able to tell you you're
full of it actually use a word with two
more letters yeah and you got to be able
to tell me I'm full of it and we're
gonna really Duke it out and Scully was
not that way secondly Scully was
basically a marketer you know and having
run Pepsi us he didn't sit there
worrying about the product he was not
fiddling with the formula for Doritos
and saying I can make this insanely
great this Dorito it was shelf space
marketing and I think Steve after a
while felt that Scully just didn't get
into how awesome the Mac was and then it
didn't help that the mat even though it
was insanely great
Scully priced it at almost 2,500 bucks
it did not sell very well Microsoft
started licensing out it's copied
version of the graphical user interface
and started dominating the computer
business and so I think the relationship
was doing fine as long as Apple was
doing fine and the Apple 2 was the
workhorse it was making the money for
the company but the Mac didn't and
so there was a horrible falling-out that
culminates on Memorial Day of 1985
before we talk a little bit more about
the falling out in the post 85 period
let's talk about the invention of the
Macintosh itself the design itself and
this is a point in the book where you
insert the great famous quote from from
jobs good artists copy great artists
steal which he took from Picasso and
then he would add and we have always
been shameless about stealing great
ideas that quote is often associated
with the genesis of the Macintosh
because of Xerox PARC and the ethical
interface what
so they take two visits to visit two
Xerox PARC and as you know Xerox had
come up with the concept of the desktop
metaphor the graphical interface more
importantly sort of a bitmap design
meaning each pixel on that screen could
be mapped to you know bits in the
microprocessor and so you can make a
beautiful machine you and I are old
enough to remember and certainly if
you're not you can go into this museum
here to remember what you have to do you
know those green phosphor letters you
know see prompts with C colon backslash
whatever command you know it was
god-awful and suddenly at Time magazine
we get the Mac and you can click and the
document appear you know you can drag
and drop well but let's oh I do a whole
big section on both the visits to Xerox
PARC and I think the misconception that
they just took the graphical interface
from Xerox PARC because it takes two
years of the most amazing designers
including Andy and others on the team to
take what the metaphor that Xerox used
and to really make it great you have to
remember Xerox came out with the start
two years before the Mac came out I
think it sold like seven copies in all
of America I mean it was a clergy bad
machine what they did when they took
that metaphor would say oh we'll take
the mouse with three buttons and totally
simplify it and you'll be able to click
and drag and drop and double click and
open things up will invent pulldown
menus and Bill Atkinson invents scale
clipping where you can have documents
looking like they're on top of other
documents so it looks like a messy
desktop we can do things so none of that
was in the Xerox original graphical
interface so I think first of all they
take the Xerox metaphor and actually
make it insanely great secondly TS
Eliot's line you know they're Falls the
shadow between the conception and the
reality well they were able to execute
on it which Xerox and others warned but
it is true that part of Steve's genius
was looking at a thousand ideas at any
given point and saying that one's great
died and this one sucks and this we're
gonna ignore but pulling together ideas
including ideas from Xerox PARC and this
is one of the times where he's pushing
this team incredibly hard reality
distortion field is then coined by I
mean at that point one of the engineers
I think Larry can you deduce his name's
in charge of the boot-up of the machine
and Steve says it's taking too long to
boot up you got to save ten seconds off
the boot up time reality distortion
field the guy says you can't it's
actually a really elegant piece of code
it can't I can't shave ten and C says if
you could save a human life would you
shave ten seconds off and Kenyon goes
well yeah so Steve goes piece of
whiteboard or whatever and says all
right say there are a million
Macintosh's and say it's ten seconds
every time somebody boots up and in the
given year it's done this number of
times if he multiplies it out and says
you can save this number of lives every
year if you shave off ten seconds an
example of the reality distortion field
working within four weeks Larry Canyon
and shaved off 28 seconds everything
about that you know you see the screen
it's a rounded rectangle
I think it's Bill Atkinson I'll get
corrected if I get some of the names
wrong but I think it's Atkins or who's
doing what's called the primitives that
you can easily put on the screen so he
does a square which is easy in a
rectangle and then he does a circle
which is hard because the microprocessor
doesn't do square
Roots but he figured out a way to do a
circle and she says yeah but you need
not only a rectangle in a circle but a
rectangle with rounded edges the guy
says well no that can't be done and why
do we need it and Steve makes him walk
around the parking lot in the
neighborhood pointing to things like
windshields and billboards and you know
don't know parking signs and screens of
computers saying rounded rectangles or
what people see every day they're more
beautiful to look at
Atkinson or how that came up with the
primitive to do a rounded rec and even
you know those thin pin stripes on the
pulldown menus fretted over them even
the Susan care doing the fonts I mean
you know Steve was there because he had
taken that calligraphy course when he
dropped out of Reed caring about the
spacing on each one of those fonts the
the perfection that he was seeking at
that point and the the almost impossible
tasks he was he was asking people to
perform engendered in the book as you
report it to two completely different
camps it seems to me it who worked for
jobs at that point there were the people
who liked but Tribble who says he push
you you'd be better for it right and
that was one of the great engineers on
it and then there are others who say
worst experience of my life out if you
if you balance not only in this case but
in other cases to the number of people
you encounter who felt one way
tremendous affection and the number of
people who felt another way what what
would you say that there's a well
they're actually three category because
a lot of people felt both yeah yeah that
it was a really agonizing experience and
the best expect but especially with the
Macintosh team or even with the team
today the overwhelming number say he
pushed me to do things I never thought I
could do he drove me nuts at times it
was the greatest experience in my life
so it premieres is a great commercial
the legendary commercial talked a little
bit about the his view of the creation
of the 1984 well the 1984 ad is
interesting because in Steve Jobs is
soul you do have the heart or soul of a
member of the counterculture a rebel a
misfit in fact even the thing different
ad start with here's to the rebels the
misfits those who think different
the 1984 ad is I think an incredible in
cultural landmark and icon obviously
because of the oil well novel we had
been thinking up until then of computers
as being centralizing and controlling
and the province of the Pentagon and the
power structure and big corporations the
notion that a computer could be personal
and empowering to the individual had
grown up a bit in opposition to that
sort of the Stuart brand Whole Earth
Catalog a view of computers for the
people and Steve was in that mentality
he also liked to think of himself as
part of the hacker ethos now the problem
with him thinking himself as a hacker
ethos is as I said he doesn't want slots
he doesn't want it to be open he doesn't
want you to be able to hack in so in
some ways he's violated the hacker ethos
by creating an appliance that you can
open up as opposed to hey put your own
software in here and plug things in but
he wants to assert that I'm still part
of that hacker ethos fighting you know
the establishment and that's that
amazing ad Ridley Scott who had just
done Blade Runner films it in London and
it's you know the woman being chased by
the thought police and all the droids
advantage of big brothers on the screen
droning and she finally throws the
hammer and it decimates Big Brother and
then says you know in you know my Apple
will introduce Macintosh find out why
1984 won't be like 1984 so they show it
at a board meeting
and all the board members are like this
at the end I think it was Phil's line of
Macy's California finally says who makes
a motion that we find a new ad agency
Scully is so frightened of it he decides
he's gonna order them to sell back the
advertising time on the Superbowl and
not run the ad Steve is furious and at
one point shows the ad - woz and woz
says why don't we just chip in and pay
for the ad they don't really you know
under Super Bowl they don't really need
to because Lee Clow and the wonderful
people who are what becomes giant day or
changes his name every Hughes who'd made
the ad Lee Clow a beach bum of a
brilliant genius who had helped do the
ad and been a guru of advertising at
Apple ever since sort of says we can't
sell the time back they just sort of
defy and just somehow don't sell the
time back so the ad runs runs really
only once or once nationally but it
becomes by many estimates including TV
Guide and Advertising Age the best
advertisement of all time it doesn't
sell well yeah we should show it yeah we
we can get the rights to show it it's
unfortunately I know and it shouldn't be
on you toggles anyway we can play it off
YouTube John wants to try to bring that
up so wonderful commercial great
premiere doesn't sell well Steve's
removed from running the Macintosh
division that that begins the end right
for him his relationship with Scully
there's a there's a massive blow-up at
the end in fact you go in the book day
by day seven days that fateful week in
May I was talking to everybody there and
Steve twice during that week tries a
counter-coup brings people up to his
house and Woodside they all sort of sort
of plot but they know that Steve
probably should not take over the
company and it's one of the great
learning experiences but he feels
abandoned and he so you know he he was
going through a period of war on doing
because he had been adopted you know
about
and father figures and he has on the
board you know author rock who had been
a father figure Mike Markkula been a
father figure John Sculley and they all
go around the room and vote against him
and abandon him and he really you know
takes it hard hello how does he recover
from that I mean when he talked to you
about that period pretty dark time what
did he say well he described vividly
every single day of that week including
where you know the food came from when
he was serving it on the patio when
they're trying to bring Mike Markkula
around so you know it's still seared
into his mom and this is almost 25 years
yeah this is Memorial Day weekend of
1985 he goes to Europe for a while
bicycles around with he then talks to
some people and comes up with the
concept of doing next computer and by
the end of 85 has recruited a handful of
people from Apple causing a lawsuit I
mean this is really bad at this point
because the board and Scully and all
think okay you're stealing our people
and it creates next you know he says in
his Stanford speech and he said to me
being fired at Apple was the best thing
to happen to me it liberated me it
helped me change I actually think it was
the experience it next that in some ways
liberated him and matured him more why
was that well you know at next
there was no board of directors sitting
on and there was no CEO brought in he
could indulge every instinct so his
instinct for design against Paul ran the
grand old designer of logos so I think
hundred thousand dollars just to do the
next logo before they even have anything
he gets you know a beautiful
headquarters with a patented staircase
you can see him there in Apple stores
but it was everything had to be he
wanted his own factory he wanted the
next to be a perfect cube and those of
you have been involved in computer
manufacturing know usually there's sort
of a draft angle that means it's 91
degrees or so so you can actually pull
it out of the mold if it's exactly 90
degrees it's harder to
now exactly 90 degrees and it meant they
had to do a special man in fact it had
to be matte black everything about it
was you know him indulging this insane
drive for perfection including building
the factory having an impure white and
having it be robotic so it is a glorious
machine that's an absolute market
failure and at the very first Macintosh
off-site he does a series of Maxim's on
the whiteboard and the first one is
don't compromise that's a great
inspiring Maxim it's also not really a
great way to run a business as Ben
Franklin said compromisers may not make
great heroes but they do make great
democracy at a certain point you have to
learn how to make trade-offs and that
don't compromise mentality he had it for
a while until he finally realized you
don't have to compromise your principles
but you have to have some sense of
balance and that's what he learned it
next and simultaneously was doing Pixar
Pixar is a wonderful example of what we
said the very beginning the intersection
of art and technology yeah a friend of
his it brought him up to George Lucas's
to meet some of George Lucas's people
Lucas was getting rid of the digital
animation software and hardware division
he had Steve thought that was really
cool he thought he could make for
consumers they build lead to do digital
rendering that never really took off but
there was one guy working there who's in
charge of making shorts to show off how
cool the machines were named John
Lasseter and he made a couple of shorts
with a Luxor lamp and then one called
ten toy and the rest as they say is
biography if not history make for him
eventually at least a Toy Story so Pixar
becomes a transformative thing in the
animation Disney he says something very
profound to you
the book about that period which is the
strain that running pixar and act
simultaneously put on him physically and
he even says I think that had something
to do with my eventually getting cancer
I don't think that's the case I don't
think you get cancer from right working
hard a stress out you know I mean but it
was a bomb when it felt that way and he
felt there was great stress he was
driving up to Pixar and he was you know
handling and then of course when he goes
back to Apple he's juggling quite a few
things I think that that was a time of
great stress in his life and also some
unhappiness next is not doing very well
those machines aren't selling and Pixar
you have to remember it was a hardware
software company and nobody's buying the
Pixar except for Disney bought a few
Pixar imaging machines but you know it's
not selling that well and so for a while
he's hemorrhaging money at both
companies and and also one of the most
wildly creative periods to write I mean
a Pixar was producing these phenomenal
well by the time they produce Toy Story
and no longer hemorrhaging money yeah um
did he long for Apple during this period
was there did he ever really fully give
up on the notion that some no happy with
his baby
Apple was his child I don't know that he
just longed for but he was deeply
frustrated that it was being screwed up
that after a while they warned inventing
new products in the product sucked and
they kept just coming out with more
lines of McIntosh's but not a better
machine they couldn't even create an
operating system you know a new Mac OS
and so I think he's watching as people
screwed up the wonderful baby it helped
create and finally it leads to his
trying well they can't create an
operating system at a certain point Gil
Amelio who is then running Apple says
okay I got a buy an operating system in
the you know it's of the B OS which is
wrong yes
days he looks at even Microsoft the
question of adopting Windows that would
have been weird and then there's this
amazing operating system that avi
devayne Ian and Steve Jobs had done it
next with a UNIX kernel to it which is
exactly what Apple needed and so
eventually Apple decides they have to
buy next to get the operating system but
you buy next to get the operating system
you also buy next to get Steve Jobs and
as I'm not sure was wise who said it but
I think it was Gil Amelio meet Steve
Jobs game over yeah Steve Jobs was back
in the saddle well in fact you tell that
whole story Amelio tried to resist that
but he'd just found himself game over in
Iran in a reality distortion field kick
yeah and then begins maybe arguably one
of the greatest decades that any
corporation
Toad's every stunning first of all he
creates you know with the new operating
system he brings Bill Gates his
doppelganger is part of the binary star
system here that falling outs and let
you know love-hate relationship gates
comes back makes an investment starts
making Microsoft Word and Excel and
others for the new Mac OS but he also
truly focuses on design y'all remember
and you probably have it here but not on
stage the first iMac I mean he beats
Johnny I've when he first goes back to
Apple in 1997 and they form this bonding
and they create the iMac you know Johnny
I've sketches it out looks almost like a
rabbit that is hopped upon your desk
steve says that's not good but they keep
playing with the model until they have
it beautiful they make it translucent
beyond the blue they even go to jelly
bean factories to say how do you make it
look right it lets you see the circuit
board inside to see how neat that
circuit board is and Johnny I've even
comes up the notion even though it's a
big desktop machine and putting a
recessed handle and the engineers say
well that's good cost too much money you
don't need a handle why would you want a
hand or you're not supposed to pick it
up
and what Steve and Johnny intuitively
understood was that computers were still
intimidating to people but the handle
gives you permission to touch it it says
I'm at your service
and so just by having that recessed
handle even if you didn't use it you
felt that the computer was being
deferential to you so that beautiful
design and when they finally have flat
screens they take the iMac and Johnny
design something with a and Steve says
no no integrity to the flat screen
you've screwed it up and he goes home
Donnie comes back to his head to Steve's
house in the backyard Lorena's planted
all these sunflowers they walk around
trying to figure out what to do and
finally you get that beautiful iMac
that's just a little dome with the
sunflower neck so that it has integrity
to it and everything they do whether
they're playing with plastic or titanium
or metals its distinguishing Apple from
those commodity machines that Dell and
HP and compact were turning out so once
he rights the ship with that strategy
when he goes back he makes a kind of
incredibly bold decision which is 2001
yeah it's it's not going to be a
computer company anymore you know they
used to take the top 100 and go off on
retreats and say here's what we want to
do next and everybody would fight to get
on that list and finally they'd get the
list 210 and then C would cross off the
bottom six or seven and say you know we
can only do four and it was stay focused
when he went back to Apple that was in
focus on you know four things desktop
laptop home professional we're not going
to make twenty lines of Mac's we're
gonna make four and so that focus but
then when he nails it and he gets that
right at the top of the list is maybe
consumer devices products and what he
does is he realizes that by having
end-to-end control of the hardware and
the software you can create a digital
hub where you can put your video camera
by firewire connect it to your computer
and manipulate your video create Adi
the one thing he screwed up slightly was
he didn't he wanted a tray slot in the
new iMac and he was furious when it
would not anyway I'm sorry he wanted one
of those you know pure slots and when
they put a tray in he was furious and he
made him eventually change it to just a
slot but it meant you couldn't burn
music CDs when Panasonic and others came
out with the burning of CDs and he was
so focused the notion of focused focused
focused he was focused on video so
they're doing iDVD and that sort of
thing he could calls up Adobe and said
you've got to make your you know video
editing software for the new Mac OS and
unlike Bill Gates who said yes and came
down and made Microsoft for the people
of Adobe said no you got too small of a
market share and as you know he never
quite forgave Adobe which is why flash
doesn't work on your iPad but the mark
of a true genius of a company is not
when you think of that just when you
think of things first
but when you actually fail to think of
something first
can you leapfrog can you catch up and so
he realizes he had gotten a stout of the
music business that others were making
CD burner trays and people were you know
people all of us were making you know
downloading music from Napster and
making playlists and burning CDs and you
couldn't really do it that well on the
Apple so he had to leapfrog and he says
we're gonna do it by making a perfect
Indian thing with a jukebox software
which is iTunes the store and would you
get your music the device itself and
when they start making the iPod he makes
it so simple because it's end-to-end
integrated with the whole thing you can
take some of the complexity and put it
on the Mac or put it in the iTunes
software so that the device itself is
not one of these complicated mp3 players
where you had to figure out how to do it
you could just look at it with that
tracked wheel and it was intuitive and
he kept saying I want to be able to get
to wherever I want whatever song I want
whatever function I want in
clicks and I want it to be intuitive and
he drove him and drove him and drove him
until the iPod becomes perfect and
that's when he leapfrogs and does the
music but it takes Apple from being
Apple computer they even changed the
name to just Apple into being in the
digital hub business first you know with
DVDs and video then really big with the
iPod and music and the iPod is hugely
successful so he starts to worry what's
gonna kill it and he realizes people
putting music on their phones will kill
it
so focuses and does the iPhone and does
it at first they do two versions of the
iPhone one with sort of a iPod modified
with the tracked wheel which wasn't very
good for a phone and then with Johnny
I've many other people and goaded on by
Microsoft and an engineer there that
Steve didn't like this notion of a
touchscreen technology when he finally
sees how the touchscreen can work he
says that doesn't that's how we're gonna
do the iPhone and so you have a series
of consumer advices devices from the
decade beginning in 2001 most
prominently the iPod the iPhone and the
iPad that totally transform industries
and at the same time he's bending other
industries in the direction of his music
industry the music industry Disney
retails the retailers he can't abide the
fact that he's making these insanely
great products and they're being sold in
big box stores we oh by clerks who have
no idea what they're doing so he comes
up with the notion of the Apple Store
which is not just a store but a whole
branding exercise and you know it's just
that notion of bending industries for
the iPod and iTunes store to work you
had to convince seven record companies
to put all their music on and
disaggregate albums and sell the songs
instead of the album so the songs for
$0.99 initially now the music companies
quite why they had their own press play
and you
they were doing their consortium
obviously Sony was trying to you know
they've done the Walkman they had a
great music division none want to come
aboard and Steve personally is like
bringing the iTunes software to the Time
Warner building showing it to Roger Ames
at Warner Music getting him aboard and
then getting you know Doug Morris at
Universal finally encircling Sony no
other CEO would have been so passionate
about just you know going at people
until they finally surrendered and
Sony's the last holdout there's a great
story Andy lack and others tell me Andy
Lac was running Sony Music itself he has
a surrender he has to put Sonam years
again but the one thing that Steve wants
is all of Dylan because he and woz in
the early days that's found every
bootleg tape that totally Dylan fanatics
it's a soundtrack of Steve's life Dylan
is a Sony artist so he wants to do all
772 tracks of Dylan as a virtual digital
set that you can buy for $199 and ELAC
at Sony says no I'm gonna jab it to him
because I need leverage we're not gonna
allow Dylan to be on Steve calls Bob
Dylan Bob Dylan with all due respect to
whether greater office at a time
slightly Spacey so doesn't quite deal
with it but sort of his manager they're
all trying to figure out Steve Jobs
talked him into it Andy lack finally
says to Bob Dylan I will write you a
check for 1 million dollars if you'll
stay out of the iTunes Store with that
dark set for you and Dylan I hate to say
it because I love Dylan takes the money
but a year later Andy lack has moved out
of Sony and Dylan's box set not only
goes on to the iTunes Store Dylan does
an iPod ad you may remember with
silhouettes and Dylan wearing the cowboy
hat and you know what it helps Dylan
more than it even helps the iPod for the
first time since 20 years he debuted
with an album at the top of the
Billboard charts because because iTunes
and the iPod had such a cachet that him
just doing that ad and
reduce them to a new generation you look
skeptical about some of those question
I'm I'm not skeptical these are actually
a lot of excellent questions I'm my
expressions meant to say where do I
start
but let me just ask you one other
question before we get into the cards
which is about the final chapter you
write if reality did not comport with
his will he would ignore it as he had
done with the birth of his daughter and
would do years later when first
diagnosed with cancer I think when I
talk to people about the question they
most wanted me to ask you tonight yeah
easily in the top three was why when he
was first diagnosed did he undertake all
these other natural non medical
solutions had two sides at least to
Steve Jobs at all times whether it's his
personal life cancer professional life
of the products he made there's a
counterculture sort of alternative
romantic sensibility of Steve and
there's the hard core engineering
scientific side estate and the cancer
was no different both sides kick in and
he spends a lot of time wrestling with
those two alternatives wrestling you
know with alternative treatments and
diets but also as I say in the book it
didn't you know get as much having his
DNA sequenced having targeted therapies
done now unfortunately it takes some
months before he does what he does in
every other aspect of his life is fine
the perfect synthesis of you know
something that is both very scientific
but also comports with his alternative
view of things and so he does it takes
longer I don't know it was implied that
had he gotten operated on right away or
something
he might have stopped the cancer I don't
you know we don't know that I mean
cancer spreads in mysterious ways so
it's quite likely the cancer had already
spread but it was somewhat typical of
Steve to say the normal rules don't
apply to me I'm going to look at this
from both an alternative viewpoint as
well as a deeply rooted scientific
viewpoint
everything in some ways that he does in
his life ends up being a synthesis of
that hippie rebel with the guy he was in
the hewlett-packard geek explorers club
it's interesting I might start with a
couple of these questions now what what
was the greatest misperception about
Steve Jobs in your mind that was
addressed or maybe that you could
address in this book I think the
greatest misperception and came right
when the book first came out and people
were quickly reading it and pulling out
anecdotes is that the petulance and the
impatience that were in bred into his
character from the very beginning was
just sort of a weird thing instead of
part of an in I mean his own personality
was integrated including with his
profession and the products he made just
like Apple products are integrated so
that perfectionism and artists
temperament or bratty temperament you
call it artist or bratty temperament
that's not some disconnected little
thing that has nothing to do with the
passion for perfection or the product
you know Drive that he had and so I try
and that's what the last chapter is
about to show how all of this was woven
together so the the you know words like
petulant and bratty are also maybe a
little euphemistic for Samaritan either
much of stronger words that you use in
the book from time to time remember I
was a Time Inc and at one point fortune
was doing a story involving his cancer
because they were the ones who reported
the cancer treatment first not my book
and other things that Steve was furious
and called up the editor and the editor
in chief I was there and you know heard
the stories and finally he says to Andy
serwer is the editor of fortune wait a
minute so what do you have here you've
discovered I'm an [ __ ]
why is that news so he was very
self-aware that
could be a strong cup of tea yeah yeah
yeah did this is an interesting question
did he have to be who he was in that way
to do most would you have to be that way
Andy you asked me to ask you know did
you have to be that way
you get done what you did and I'm gonna
back off a little from giving you a
great answer because I'm a storyteller I
had to write about the person who was in
front of me that's who he was so I wrote
the story of him this is not a how-to
book this is not a manual for do you
have to be this way to run a company
well of course you don't I mean they're
very nice people who run very successful
companies and they're also total
[ __ ] who are total failures and
running companies that said I am NOT
trying to say here's the way to do it
like Steve did I am trying to write a
book about a flesh-and-blood human being
who I didn't know all of his aspects but
when I knew them I tried to tell that
story and part of that story is being
driven or that's euphemistic and had he
not been that way I doubt he would have
been as successful on the other hand I
suspect there were other ways to get
things done at times but you know when
you say did he have to be that way my
only job is to tell you what the way he
was because I'm just a biographer not a
preacher or a management consultant do
you think that question will be answered
with the with the sort of the luxury of
distance and time that's a yeah I mean I
guess you know Clayton Christensen's and
other great management gurus could
probably do a case study of you can take
all the Jack Welch's and blah blah blah
and say you know I was 60 minutes are
saying wasn't he you know did he have to
be so hard did he have to be so tough as
a wait a minute you worked for Don
Hewitt you know Don euro was a genius he
was also a real pain in the butt we all
know people like that I guess you could
do a study of
bosses tough bosses jerks whatever and
correlated somehow with the regression
analysis and say who's more successful
but that's way above my pay grade are
you writing the screenplay and would you
choose George Clooney the reports of the
movie or premature and way overdone and
I'm not even talking about it but I'm
not involved
can you see George Clooney in this role
and I am NOT a movie person in fact I
had trouble when I was dealing with
Steve Steve went over every frame of
Pixar movies the way he went over every
chamfer and curve of the first Macintosh
and he would say something about Finding
Nemo or whatever and I remember having
to go back and quickly download those
movies because I just don't know it's
one of my blind spots in fact when I was
at a tour of time I was famous for
making really bad movie cover so asking
me who should play what in a movie is
all right this I'll give you a pass on
that one so I'm gonna read you the
preface that is on this card it says on
behalf of archivists and historians out
there yeah what were Steve's
stipulations about using the interviews
you collected for this book and where
will they ultimately be deposited yeah
most of them are notes some transcripts
of the four or five formal interviews he
gave me mine notes we'll go somewhere
maybe we should talk but not for another
20 or 30 years and not I mean partly
because Steve and then the people around
Steve you know you know would say things
that could be very hurtful or they'd say
don't you know or they you know say
something just offhanded especially
Steve about certain things and the
things I didn't put in the book and the
things I would have to take out of those
you know my notes just because they were
unnecessary to understanding Steve and
probably you know in the interest of
kindness you don't want to hurt you know
people with certain comments Oh
I will someday go through my notes and
if it's the 20 year rule maybe some of
the things will have you know gone by
the wayside someone picked up on that
quote about great artists steal and said
he said that yet he resented Bill Gates
and Google and many others for many
years for stealing from Apple as he saw
it how did his Zen self reconcile this
Steve was not an expert at reconciling
conflicting things Emerson and many
others have great quotes have had people
can body conflicting thoughts at the
same time Steve was totally ballistic
first at Bill Gates and Microsoft for
ripping off as he put it the Macintosh
graphical interface and then of course
famously berating and saying it to me in
the book with words of one syllable how
he felt Android and Google had ripped
off the Apple mobile operating system
you know did he know he didn't try to
reconcile that with the fact but I will
say he didn't rip off Xerox and there
was a financial deal Xerox invested a
million dollars in the Apple there was
an exchange of Technology I think you
know he has some right to feel that he
came up or Apple came up with both the
beautiful Macintosh operating system and
then it pretty much is copied by Windows
and likewise the mobile operating system
you can argue as for ten years in court
there were an argument about whether you
can you know copyright or the look and
feel whether there's an intellectual
property theft there but I can
understand why he was pissed off
given his mercurial there's a great
story in the book about mercury all of
the world and dictatorial style how was
he still able to engender such
creativity
in loyalty in his work well first of all
tell the mercurial stories it's the part
of the self-awareness of Steve because
he was mercurial so he's showing off the
next computer at Symphony Hall here when
it's being unveiled and among other
things he had helped invent digital
books I mean they didn't exist but he
put a thesaurus and all of Shakespeare's
work in digital form and necks so he's
showing off the authority Soros and he
says sometimes I've called mercurial you
know let me look it up or whatever and
it says you're changeable moods whatever
and says answered him you know saturnine
and then it describes saturnine he who
doesn't have enough emotions Kant said
well maybe it's not so bad to be
mercurial is it so I think he understood
his mercurial nature and that that was a
part of who he was and having said that
I've never forgotten the second half of
the course it had given that he was that
way how did he and Gender such
creativity and look when you're creating
a machine as insanely great as that even
if you're in the middle of the night
saying this code is socks you got to
make it better by the time you've
created as an engineer the original
Macintosh you are loyal to the genius
and the vision there and people who have
strong personalities either can turn
people off or they can say hey I got
inspired here and got to be on a team
and look the proof is I hate cliches
like this pooping in the pudding but
look at the team he even has it Apple if
he's that bad of a boss why do so many a
players stay with him well cuz they like
to work on a team with only a players
and if he got if he ran off a lot of B
players that doesn't mean that that team
at Apple filled with a players you know
they're quite loyal to him if you talked
a little bit about the relationship
between Larry Ellison and Steve Jobs
they both describe each other's
collateral
you know best friend it was you know a
deep friendly relationship one of my
favorite anecdotes is I think 90 late 96
when the question of Steve coming back
to take over Apple is first being kicked
around and Larry Ellison says why don't
we buy Apple why don't I launch a
hostile takeover all by Apple we'll put
you back and it'll set it into motion
again it will all make a lot of money
and Steve finally says I think I might
go back to Apple but I don't want you to
invest I don't want you to buy it
I don't want me to invest I want to be
able to go back at $1 a year and no
ownership of it and Larry Ellison says
but Steve if you do it and you come back
that way and it makes it a great company
again how am I gonna make it how are we
going to make money you know if we don't
invest in it and buy it and they were
walking along a beach and Steve grabbed
him by both shoulders says Larry this is
why it's important I'm your friend you
don't need any more money
it didn't well I won't go that I'm not
doing a couple a couple more questions
first well before I get to those two let
me just ask you quickly about the the
current technology this great
conversational interface that Siri
represents Harry
did he talk much about that with you
yeah what the vision for that is yeah I
mean I do think that the simplest most
natural interfaces have always been his
passion and there's no simpler one than
just talking I did not know the name
Siri but we talked a little bit and I
was careful in the book even though he
told me a lot of things that he in
detail what he wanted to do I decided
you know I shouldn't put you know in
things that he might not be able to do
in that Apple may be working on for the
next couple of years but at the last
board meeting when he tenders his
resignation as CEO they have a lunch
afterwards all the engineers bring out
the various things that they're working
on and one of them which I knew would
come out pretty soon so I'll put in the
book is this voice recognition thing and
I do have Steve trying their panic
because they know Steve it's not feeling
very well but he's been brought into
this meeting the day that he's gonna try
to make it look bad so yes you know what
is now called Siri you know if you cut
do I need an umbrella tomorrow says you
know the prediction is for sunny day
tomorrow in Palo Alto so it really is
doing the beautifully so finally Steve
says are you a man or are you a woman
and they all kind of hold their breath
because you know he's trying to trick
the machine and Siri is very good the
two layers of it and it says they have
not yet assigned me a gender
and they all breathe a sigh of relief
and Steve thinks it's great so he loved
that technology by the way Bill Gates
was alway having everybody's been trying
to crack voice-recognition yeah yeah
what do you think of the Apple that he
leaves behind you've talked about the
team and the great group that he's built
there certainly there's rumor to be this
product roadmap that goes on and on but
the history of technology companies with
a founder like this and someone driving
it with a vision like this leaving is
not great overall what do you think
about where Apple goes from here without
Steve Jobs what the last meeting I told
you about when he goes to the board and
does that lunch somebody at the lunch
makes fun of HP because it that day or
that week had gotten out of the tablet
business was either getting in all right
you know out of the PC you know is
totally confused and Steve said wait a
minute
you know he stops the person who's
making fun of the troubles at Hewlett
Packard so I was 13 Bill Hewlett gave me
my first job and he and Packard created
a company that was imbued with their DNA
that was designed not only to make a
calculator and then make a computer and
make other things but to continue and
last and continue to make new products
and come up with new ideas even after
they were gone and those bozos screwed
it up for Hewlett and Packard I don't
want that to happen at Apple and he
tried deeply to fight off the bozo
explosion so there was only a great team
of a players but also to say there's a
simple simple thing that Apple stands
for which is the intersection of great
creativity in the humanities with great
engineering and technology he said
that's what Disney did you know that's
what a lot of people have done there are
companies that last IBM is almost 101
years old I think Apple has imbued in
its genetic code
this desire to drive great design and
artistic creativity with great design
and with great engineering and
technology and it will be at that
intersection and the people there now
are capable of keeping it at that
intersection you know ten years from now
twenty five years from now look Disney
ups and down ups and down but you still
know what Disney stands for and it's
doing fine right now
after a few rough patches since Walt
Disney died I would have had to wager
and unlike Rick Perry I am a betting man
not $10,000 but I would wager that a
generation from now even a century from
now Apple will still exist at the
intersection of the humanities and the
technology so that's Apple now that's
one final question about Steve Jobs so a
hundred years ago the great
industrialists and philanthropist
Carnegie Rockefeller Mellon built
institutions as well as corporate
legacies and that legacy survives see
jobs yet he lived longer might have done
the same thing but he chose not to do it
for whatever reason now and his legacy
is Apple but it's built on a rather
shifting sandbar of Technology so a
hundred years from now you've talked
about what you think Apple will do what
do you think the legacy of Steve Jobs
will be as people look back on him in
this era well I do I did ask him what I
mean in the last five or six pages of
the book is just him talking outright
about what's your legacy it's putting
something back in the flow of history
after you built on those who were you I
asked him what was his greatest creation
thinking maybe it'd be the iPad or
whatever he said no Apple the company
because products come and go but the
hard part is making a company that will
continue to make good products so I do
think Apple will be his legacy but also
more specifically the legacy will be
somebody
who
truly transformed industry after
industry by pulling together great ideas
and driving the technology to support
them I mean look at the iPad people made
fun of it I was there when he launched
it there were all sorts of articles what
is it you know an iPhone on steroids
nobody makes a tablet work the iPad is
now whether I'll walk into a doctor's
office or you know anywhere else it is
transforming industry after industry two
billion dollars last year just in the
industry of creating apps for it the
textbook industry you know Carnegie was
great with education philanthropy Bill
Gates was great with education
philanthropy in the end the iPad may
change education as much as any of the
Carnegie schools so I think he's got a
pretty solid legacy if you look at each
of those industries he transformed so we
often ask our authors to do a short
reading at the end and you graciously
agreed to read the coda of the biography
and I wonder if you would do that for us
now yeah thank you I as I said I end
I'll start earlier on I do and one more
thing his signature phrase and I do say
bhaag refers is supposed to have the
last word but this is one of Steve Jobs
and even though he didn't impose his
legendary control I suspect I would not
be conveying the right feel for him and
the way he asserted himself in any
situation if I just shuffled him on
history stage without letting him have
some of the last words so I really take
a series of interviews I did with them
about his legacy and just let him talk
without me getting in the way
but then the coda is about a son one
sunny afternoon when in the back garden
of his house he wasn't feeling well and
he reflected on death and I say he
talked about his experiences in India
almost four decades earlier his study of
Buddhism his views on reincarnation
in his views on spiritual transcendence
quote I'm about 50/50 on believing in
God he said for most of my life I felt
there must be more to our existence than
meets the eye unquote he admitted that
as he faced death he might be
overestimating the odds out of a desire
to believe in the afterlife quote I like
to think that something survives after
you die it's strange to think that you
accumulate all this experience and maybe
a little wisdom and it just goes away so
I really want to believe that something
survives that maybe your consciousness
indoors and then he fell silent for a
long time and then he said but on the
other hand perhaps it's just like an
on/off switch he said click you die
you're gone and then he paused again
long pause and he smiled slightly quote
and maybe that's why I never like to put
on all switches on Apple devices that's
the end